this is a production of Cornell
University
and I'd like to thank balls laying hands
of visiting scholar program for hosting
me here today and of course all the
folks at Cornell who always give me such
a warm welcome when I visit so light is
the most important environmental factor
for photosynthetic organisms and I
thought I understood it I've worked with
plants all of my life I did graduate
studies on light acclamation of week and
also light acclamation and photo
protection in an Antarctic green algae
so I knew light but it wasn't until 2007
when I joined Helio spectra that was
founded by plant physiologist there were
the two of us working with LEDs and it
was then that the light came on and we
grew a small engineering team along with
with a couple of plant physiologist and
that's when I started fusing engineering
into my plant physiological research
so this is a photograph of the different
colors of the sky and when I saw this it
prompted me to start experimenting with
spectral compositions to see if I could
replicate these colors and below is the
panel of photographs I took a styrofoam
in the back of a growth cabinet where I
did these experiments so it showed one
that we can replicate these colors and
two we have a really powerful tool now
to create any kind of spectral condition
that we want I wasn't the first person
to be obsessed with light quality this
is a cyano meters that was invented by
de Sousa and he used it in the Swiss
Alps to measure the blueness of the sky
it was also used in 1802 by Alexander
von Humboldt when he characterized the
South American volcano he did a complete
physical and botanical characterization
of the Balkan volcano and he was able to
classify the color of the sky as he
ascended the volcanoes and on the same
note and light changes and I think when
I saw this figure that was published by
new Albright I it was shocking Lew
showed that there is a large annual
variation in daily light integral on any
given day in Ithaca New York and this is
an annual variation this is a 14-year
study so light is variable the ppfd is
variable and on a shorter timescale it
can be seen here that light and ppfd
sorry it's watts per square meter on the
y-axis there but we also see really
short-term fluctuations in the Sun now
these studies are usually performed to
understand and improve performance
estimations for solar energy systems and
so they look at these very fast
fluctuations in the Sun to see how
they're going to affect the grid so here
we've got seconds on the x-axis and you
can
see but the if you take the average of
the three hour long fragment it's 450
watts per meter squared but we can see
that it jumps from 100 to 700 watts per
meter squared in a matte in less than a
second so this may not have implications
for solar energy systems but plants can
certainly be Texas and and it's made me
really interested in dynamic lighting
and fluctuating lighting for controlling
a crop growth so at the same time that
PFD is is fluctuating the spectrum
fluctuates as well throughout the day as
the clouds pass over you get a blue and
rich spectrum under that piece of cloud
and then when that moves it comes to a
more flat spectrum this is a greenhouse
in Sweden that I lived in for three days
with my assistant measuring light and
the physiological state of the plant
there basil was getting to the grocery
store Hofstede and they didn't know
whether it was happening at the end of
you know the it's life in the greenhouse
or during transportation so we monitored
light for three days and just examined
the environment did physiological
testing and found out it was a
temperature the delivery truck so but
during that time I was able to study the
spectrum and PFD during the day under
shade around our thermo curtains etc and
that was a really useful study so plants
have evolved for 400 million years under
fluctuating light and and this can be on
a long or short-term time scale so why
not utilize this in our in large scale
growing also why not use the intrinsic
properties of LEDs to modulate our crops
so how is this done well there are two
systems and plants that sense detect
light and then signal to the plant what
to do and I'm just going to quickly go
through them here so the first one is
the photoreceptor system that we're all
familiar with
and it induces responses ranging from
immunity and defense right up to
flowering there are 15 different
photoreceptors we've got the you loops I
did the button which like but there we
go so we've got the UV r8 here which is
the UV photoreceptor primarily involved
in defense and photo protection we've
got the cryptochromes which absorb from
blue up until the green and they're
involved in biochemistry as well as
circadian rhythms primarily the photo
tropen our movement there another blue
photoreceptor family and the site loop
is a timekeeper also absorbing in the
blue we've got the phytochromes which
are just so well known and well
characterized and they absorb and are
activated across the spectrum a couple
of these are reversible most of them are
reversible but primarily cryptochromes
and the phytochromes are reversible
using different spectra of light and so
they really do provide a molecular
switch for us so here we have the same
the same diagram we have the
photoreceptors here there is no green
photoreceptor elucidated yet but
phytochrome absorbs and the green as
well as cryptochrome so in a way they do
function in photo receptions in the
system so we've got the photoreceptors
we've got the action so these are the
peaks maximum for the action spectra for
the various photoreceptors and you can
see that it goes down from 280
nanometers which is the UVB so area
right up to 733 nanometers for the far
red spectrum except right here there's a
gap from about 600 to 660 nanometers
which is kind of interesting but I came
across a paper describing the option
spectrum of PS to a photosystem ii photo
damage
and it occurred right in this area so
maybe that has something to do with this
I'm not sure
looking at the activation time so I work
in engineering so we're always looking
at rate constants and timing and trying
to do things as fast as possible and so
they work relatively quickly when you
see the next sensing system you'll see
that this might be even be a little
sluggish so this brings us to the
photosynthetic sensing system or
photosynthetic control as we know it and
when I did my PhD in masters I worked in
the lab where we looked at this in
various organisms from cyanobacteria
right up to poplar and and looking at
photosynthetic control of these
organisms so what does it elicit it
elicits a lot of responses that help
sustain photosynthesis in a changing or
fluctuating environment so you've got
light capture photosynthetic efficiency
and co2 assimilation you've also got
rapid accumulation of pigments to help
protect the photosynthetic machinery and
when you grow under conditions where
photosynthetic control is active then
you also have protection and defense and
in long term you can actually adjust the
height and other morphological factors
so what is this so here is my very
simple schematic and photosynthesis we
have two photosystems photosystem 2 and
photosystem 1 that work
electrochemically in series we've got a
mobile plasto quinone electron carrier
that transports the electrons from
photosystem 2 where they're extracted
from water and brings them through a
series of carriers to photosystem 1
where they reduce an ADP to NADPH at the
same time plus the Quinton pool drops
off protons into the lumen and that this
drives in ATP A's to generate ATP so
you've got the two chemical energy
components that the plant cell uses
so what is photosynthetic control
anytime you have a situation where you
have light energy exceeding chemical
energy utilization by the plant you have
an upset and that upset triggers
hundreds of genes and one and twenty six
different pathways that will help
protect the machinery against of energy
and balance so typically this is done by
subjecting the plant to highlight
because then you're increasing the
energy input at low temperature it works
as well because you're decreasing the
reaction rates of photosynthesis that
you end up with excess energy again and
when you have a nutrient deficiency
you're limiting the number of electrons
sinks so again you're pushing this
energy balance in the chloroplasts out
of whack and that is going to signal all
of these responses so in during
photosynthetic control you've got the
two main signals it's the Delta pH
across we fly the Koide membrane and
reaction oxygen species and the redox
state of ferredoxin and thyroid auxins
and there's a few others as well that
aren't on here so we control the size of
balance using the spectrum as well so
this is where our LEDs can come in so
ps2 we call it p 6a v absorbs
preferentially at 680 nanometers and
photosystem 1 is p 700 those absorbs
preferentially at 700 nanometers now we
have something that we call PS 2 light
PS 2 light over excites PS 2 compared to
ps1 and this is wavelengths below 680
nanometer so any red or blue LED fixture
used in plant growth is basically giving
the plant PS to light how does the plant
deal with this it will adjust the
stoichiometry of PS 2 PS one unit so
they'll have more PS one relative to PS
2 to deal with
like you never see it in nature pf1
light of course is uh when you go up to
to the far read and if you have a good
balance you should have a good straight
qiyamah tree of your photosystems and
smooth sailing the electrons right
through to carbon metabolism this is the
same diagram but just depict it a little
differently and again I've got the time
constants of these reactions I listed so
we have light harvesting and charge
separation which is when the electron in
photosystem 2 goes from water to the QB
binding site we call that charge
separation this occurs long sento and
pìkô second level electron transport
occurs on milliseconds to second time
scale and you've got carbon metabolism
just primarily minutes to occur so you
have orders of magnitude difference in
the rate constants for photosynthesis
and we can certainly drive LEDs at the
millisecond and second timescales you
should see erratically be able to drive
them at nanosecond time scales but I've
never seen that yet in a practical way
so we can utilize LEDs for that so how
do we do that with pulse width
modulation which is a really popular way
to give a LEDs here we've got the duty
cycles for LEDs so the duty cycle is the
percentage of time the light is on so at
100% the light is on there's no off
period at 80% you've got the lights on
it's 80% of the time during the period
50% twenty and then zero percent duty
cycle of course the lights are all off
hopefully although this can be a
challenge sometimes for lighting fixture
developers and here we've just got sort
of a pictogram describing this so we can
utilize this to help sort of unbalanced
the chloroplast to achieve these
responses that might be beneficial
warburg or we can do the opposite is
drive it so that we've got efficient
photosynthesis under other circumstances
that might throw the balance off Warburg
found that forty milliseconds of dark
was adequate to oxidize the whole
photosynthetic electron transport chain
so to keep photosynthesis continuing you
need give it forty milliseconds to
darken in a period and you'll get all
those electrons moving along to carbon
metabolism and the reaction sensors open
and able to accept a photon tennyson
later on using a 680 nanometer LED found
that 198 milliseconds is dark in the
period was too much it decreased the
rates of photosynthesis and and so we
need to find the balance and we need to
understand the effects of pulse width
modulation on for the chemistry and
photosynthesis when you're looking at
different fixtures and you call the
companies and I do this all the time I
ask are you doing using pulse width
modulation and it's very popular to do
that in human centric lighting but we're
easy to trick plants aren't they see a
lot more than we do quite often they
don't know it's something that they
don't think about so our question is
photosynthetic controls rapid can we use
PWM to to adjust this and play with this
one last thing before I move away from
LEDs is the phase of pulse width
modulation this is a great study
published by schemata at all where they
use red and blue LEDs so here we have
100 percent duty cycle the R and B LEDs
are running full-time here we've got a
forty five percent duty cycle where the
red and blue LED are going on and off in
phase here we have the red and blue LEDs
again a forty five percent duty cycle
but they're going off and on
different phases and let me tell you
I've just designed a six wavelength
fixture so and got the engineers to make
it so all of the LEDs when we pulse with
modulated will come on and off in phase
so that we don't have to do this because
we look at these around adopts as plants
you've got most growth for better growth
better performance that looks like in
your plants grown under the forty five
percent duty cycle when they are in
phase so that throws a bit of a wrench
into the works for light designers you
have to go to the papers and engineering
paper probably not they probably did but
but no quantitative data
yeah yeah I'd have to actually read
through and and see their their methods
and statistics again so to hundreds of
experiments of light quality and plants
and Porter pointed out in his 2010 paper
that none of these experiments have been
set up in such a way that we can
actually quantify and compare the
analyses they're different wavelengths
different peak Maxima different
temperatures nutrients is no way we can
generalize and and sort of make a
unified theory for LEDs and plant growth
so I'm going to show a bit of the data
that we've generated in the lab over the
last couple of years and I just want to
bring home three main findings that I
think are really interesting so looking
at the the different fixtures that we
grew under and we do all of our work
under sole source lighting at RPI we've
got PFD here along the y-axis and of
course wavelengths here we've got the
cool white fluorescent pay attention to
this you think about it a bit later
which is a nice you know standard
spectrum that we were all used to
Illuma Tex is this red line here so
there's a peak at 660 tiny little bit of
white you can't see it here but I can
measure it with my with my spectrometer
a little bit of green and and then the
red or the blue peak here at about 450
nanometers the Phillips is 660
nanometers red 470 nanometers in blue
the velour is a phosphor converted led a
that means that it's a blue LED
typically with a phosphor spread on the
lens to broaden the spectrum they're
using blue but they're using UV now as
well for some of these false or
conservative LEDs and so here you've got
a peak at about 4:40 and this broad
shoulder over the green and red into the
far red for those of you that aren't
familiar with the with the spectrum this
is blue from 400 to 500 green red and
far red so the last one is Fiona the
Danish lamp and we've got a peak here at
660 and a peak here at 434 nanometers so
we grew under all of these spectra are
our model organism in the lab is lettuce
and this is red lettuce roots I grown
under cool light fluorescent Phillips
Fiona and Valera and I'd like to just
focus on these two either two red and
blue LEDs they look identical to the
naked eye but there's a thirty-six
nanometer difference in the peak maximum
of the blue LED and look at the
difference in the plant they're
significantly smaller and what we'll see
some results in in the net
st. ppfd of 200 micromoles same
temperatures a nutrient solution same
co2 same relative humidity
yeah this is done at RPI actually but in
Sweden you can mimic with anything
yeah actually and I have some some data
at the end of this talk which I wasn't
going to present where I did spectral
analyses on an island in the North
Atlantic off Gothenburg just north of
Gothenburg and yeah it was very blue in
the morning and then it evened out
during the day and in the evening again
there was also a blue light present so
yeah probably from the scattering and
it's always cloudy there Oh probably a
lot of blue light enrichment went off so
just to look at the fresh wait for green
lettuce red lettuce basil and the height
on basil between these two red and blue
fixtures you can see that they're
significantly different so what is the
grower to do how are they going to
choose even the blue and red fixtures
when it can have such a huge effect on
your crop I was thinking that the Fiona
would be really good because I had a
lower blue and I thought all that will
activate a lot of the biochemistry and
you know and sort of thickness of the
leaf but it it was actually not a good
the plants were significantly smaller
and we withdrew it from our trials after
two or three goes and we replaced it
with a new Lumet X fixture which I
showed you it's essentially blue and red
has a tiny bit of white which gives a
little bit of green to the spectrum so
here we have red LED of rooks I again
the LED treatment there was no
significant difference in the fresh
weight however the cool white
fluorescent did have sufficiently lower
fresh rates at day 16 the anthocyanin
was highest that we always see under the
cool white fluorescent so we're now
delineating which one of those Peaks are
actually responsible so we've gone
through the green it does get a bit but
I think it's actually going to be a
combination
couple Peaks in that spectrum such as
responsible scissors so we have high
anthocyanins here the red pigment and we
have extremely low biochemistry
occurring in the in the Ender's of a
lawyer fixers and we've measured
carotenoids chlorophylls and
anthocyanins and we see the same in all
so looking at the I see as a silent we
tried different cultivars so we have
groups I here we've got an to finding
concentrations there red salad bowl
outrageous regice and red tails and we
can see in more cases than not under the
foster congruent spectrum you have lower
anthocyanin concentration so we threw an
even more cultivars and here we have our
standard roots I and we have the fella
Nova red butter and red oak leaf under
I'm calling the Illuma text here regimen
white because usually when I speak at
conferences in the engineering world I
don't like to give the trade the name
away of the fixture we've got the velour
foster converted cool white fluorescent
and we've got the Philips red and blue
look at the difference in the morphology
the leaf size when you touch these
plants you can feel the difference the
read better under the limit X very hairy
and the Culinary Institute would say
how's bad mouthfeel it's not very
pleasant to eat but that changes
depending on the spectrum look at this
under the cool whites where as the
plants can't even stand up and this is
repeated this we've repeated this now
about six or seven times and we're
seeing the same results every time so
one common thread because we can't
there's no commonality here but one
common thread is that under these foster
converted fixtures there are poor and
Santa fine and concentration so this led
to the question of is it something
specific in the phosphor conversion of
LEDs that is responsible for this
and I met router Sauer at the several
actually engineering conferences and he
is an engineer that works for Ludmila's
and I discussed this problem with them
but one of the problems with that I
could never really see if it was the
foster conversion because the other LEDs
that I'm comparing to you have different
special ratios so it might be the
spectral ratio and not the phosphor so
we SPECT out some and these are just
photos of different foster's that rotate
I took at a trade booth at this
conference they're using up to five
different fosters4 one LED to actually
get a you know different spectral
distribution it's quite fantastic so
while you're in i SPECT out some
fixtures that has roughly 20% blue 20%
green and 60% red we find that's a
really nice spectral ratio to grow under
and so we achieve that so we have line
these are my growth cabinets here we've
got what we call the lime LED the greens
the purple of course is no green to the
Loya and then we have direct emissions
LEDs that we built ourselves and at this
point we're just running them on an RGB
red green blue program so our our
numbers are pretty good closest we could
get them and here we have the spectral
distribution so we've got photon flux
density and wavelength here and we've
got our RBG so we've got the red at 660
green at 5:30 and blue at 450 we've got
the greens and the lines LEDs which are
these lines here so I'll fight be
different we've got the Valera which is
this big one and I'm not fitting the
purple of course there's no green so
where are we seeing differences so
rather than finding commonalities but in
the plants I'm looking for commonality
in the spectra so what is it about this
spectrum that is
and so we see the velour has very little
green competin you're going to see why
this is important can compare to the
line in the green it's cause this big
area here right where the action
spectrum for photo damages but then you
think it would make amplifying and to
protect itself it's not and then it's
got a little bit of a difference here in
far-red I didn't take that into account
and I suspect the light that was my
mistake because because there's quite a
difference there between far-red between
the fixtures so let's look at some data
so this is that essentially foster
converted versus direct emission LEDs
and the yield is greater for the lime in
green and aloha
however the anthocyanin is much lower so
we so not all Fosters are created equal
so spectrum marriage matters I'm
assigning this most spectrally sensitive
than yield and not all fosters are
created equal which is great so the next
work was can we use the spectrum to
modulate plant so here is a velour grown
plant and a cool light fluorescent plant
what happens when we shift a plant from
a non bio chemically active spectrum to
biochemistry active one and here's 24
hours we were able to increase the
anthocyanin concentration 18 fold and
I've got a small movie here
24 hours this is a time-lapse of 48
hours
and again different plants within a
single cultivar no not officially we all
have our favorites but I would love to
do that absolutely so this is unhook
this has grabbed me and yes no
unfortunately not
I'm in the semiconductor lab so I'm kind
of building it up I've got a
spectrophotometer and I've got you know
just an that I've got access now to HPLC
but I would love to actually I did the
shift experiment back and it's about 24
to 48 hours just depends on the life
history of the pint of it yeah so we can
shift it back and change the more fault
and morphology changes as well we can
just move it back and forth so it kind
of you know why not grow a plant under
LEDs that produces large biomass and at
the end finish it off so that we can
pack it full of nutrients and maybe save
energy at the same filling is sort of my
series I'm going to have to speed up
here to the last bit so one interesting
thing I you know I did a lot of worked a
lot in photochemistry I'm really
interested in energy in the chloroplast
and this is my pulse amplitude modulated
parameter that I got out and used during
the shift to see what was happening to
the plants so we've got effective
quantum yield so the probability that a
photon will be used in the photochemical
act and here we have the lower it is the
less efficient to this so here we've got
the plants at time zero there was pretty
good at point six four it's reasonable
but when we shifted and this is one
minute after the shift we saw an
increase in effective quantum yield
throughout the 24 hour shift and then we
shifted it back here and it in it
decrease and again we were ever able to
measure this within one minute and the
reason it took me a minute was because I
had to jump behind a laser curtain and
press start on the computer otherwise I
had an assistant at that time we could
have actually done it a bit faster not
for the chemical quenching is
the dissipation of absorbs light energy
is heat typically through the
xanthophyll cycle indicates up there
something wrong with blockage and it has
to get rid of that energy during the
before the shift it was relatively it
was normal values but high during the
shift it went down shifted it back to
the original spectrum and it goes back
up this makes really good sense but it
shows how we can detect this and and
this is fantastic so I started with a
bunch of undergraduates building
detectors in the lab so this is my first
the first prototype this is the
excitation light this is a photodiode
picking up the chlorophyll fluorescence
and you can see how close we're working
with to the plant here is my my my very
expensive German pulse amplitude
modulation fluorometer so here we have
low temperature for doing abyssion the
open circles are measured using the crc
student device and the dark circles are
my commercially bought device were right
on measuring stress with both detectors
excellent but let's move further second
round of students came in this is our
second prototype we've got the
excitation light here we've got the
photo diodes there we're working at 40
centimeters from the plant and we're
able to detect about a half of a 10 20
flat this was pulled from an engineering
students report so you can see that they
had to indicate that this is a plant so
it's a lot of fun it is more than one
plant they should have dog bark through
that I guess good point so we had a dual
of the Centers here on dark adapting
plants just video same measuring the
maximum quantum efficiency of
photosystem q we can see during shifting
basal from 23 degrees to 5 degrees we
get the standard decrease in SE / FM
using the Student Center we're seeing
again the same thing then I thought okay
this is it
I'm sensing all the time because we have
these sensors and I've got a group of
students coming into the lab to build
more the summer hope
we can get some at Cornell as well so
here we've got a 16 hour photo period
and this is the signal emanated from the
plant at 740 nanometers and this is a
signal that we usually detect with the
Pan 680 nanometers so 640 is a bit more
complicated signal I can talk about it
more to anybody who's interested but for
the sake of time I want now one thing we
noticed this is oscillation over and
over again we've done this about 10 on
lettuce and basil about 10 different
crops and what we see is this is the
chlorophyll fluorescence yield when it's
high photosynthesis is down regulated
when it's low photosynthesis is running
smoothly so in the morning when the
lights come on it's getting all the
enzymes ready for carbon assimilation
and then it flattens out during the day
here about 10 hours into the 16 hour
photo period chlorophyll fluorescence
goes well so photosynthesis is being
down regulated now what should we do
should we turn the lights down and save
energy when it's not apparently not
using it in photosynthesis or do we use
spectral combinations to try to mitigate
this open stomata force it to not have
that afternoon nap so those are two
questions that I have but I really like
to work on together and here we have
death which is again the students forgot
to water plants and actually all of this
data is uploaded to the cloud and I can
check it regularly from home and I can
tell exactly when they didn't come in
and when they did so they're learning
they're learning so with circadian
rhythm because we're seeing that here
what they do in animal systems as they
say okay put it in the dark continuous
dark and see if you see that oscillatory
pattern but I can't do that with plants
so we put it in continuous light and
here's a 24-hour here we've got another
death by dehydration experiment and
we're seeing the same oscillation this
is super exciting and so a one last
thing we did this during growth of basil
we can see similar oscillatory pattern
happening here and of course an increase
in growth slowing fluorescence because
they're filling out the flat and getting
a bit taller so whether in a greenhouse
or a plant factory light definitely
matters and maybe we should be thinking
now that we have the ability to turn off
and on a light source at 200 nanoseconds
maybe we should be thinking about how to
use that to modulate plants that are
used to this so we need more knowledge
pets acclimate in a different way we
need to understand that and we need to
integrate this into control systems with
the potential outcome of saving energy
so I couldn't have done this alone my
lab is three years old now at RPI and
just want to thank all of the support
staff Bob Carla check has been really
supportive of this work and of course
all of my undergraduate students that
have contributed to the work devotion
today thank you very much happy faces
ramya I was just I was just a student
enters no presentation the blue line is
we must to photodiodes in it so we've
got a 680 filters to 740 top well that's
why I'm going to be testing in Asia like
it is the Automator as one a little
further and bigger for that website so
important to speak with in here
and of course the appeals of people
dependent on the height and the
expectation like reputation identities
have to be available and in speaking
average most as barometers were
factoring impulses that in the old Texas
that they were in default intensity at
the bright Sun we could be about 2500
like but now we're using actually
imposes a thousand twenty thousand
measurements and you can try to use that
in this kind of tensing he kills one so
we have actually we're not saturating
which is our nation's living have a bus
monitor Geneva do you have a question
I like I'm here when you did your 24
hour Central Community experiment and
video I've kind of been a number of
years and you think of mature plant I
would have acted responsibly you know
using you can finish plant yes because
it yes because of this larger times as
well like any time I have anything going
on like shift things and yeah we can see
it under older plants as well like
everything great 21 to 28 days hon we
got you control the other question in
government I'm seriously like company BW
letting countries we'll talk about like
recipes like how we go for our here's a
lamp that you can develop a recipe for
you
how to develop the combination there if
you have a lens with overheat and like
you want 20% of glue or 80 that's kind
of the lighter but when you're merging
with a pinch eight years developing
light dr. paster 7-channel a far better
person and it takes a couple here
village you be confident that I don't
really like calming excess but I'm
closer college life
algorithm or algorithm let me see that
that before because we have to be
something that just didn't make sense to
be seen at my flowers I very it's harder
than that
total press results on approach will
also really only be transferable I
posted in broken did he try to use a
green help whether you're in Tucson or
New York or terrible that's right but if
there's a lot of artists by complete
it's like cold dark light especially not
when you've got the lights on but any
tweets into your nutrient solution and
your temperature and any considered
growing conditions will alter it as well
so what I find some it takes it into
their souls are pledging area it would
be different if they didn't replicate my
groin most emotion versus
you did
you can't
sure and when I envision that is like we
have measurements we would show that
that changes today we do develop some
dynamic lighting everybody's numbers
kill me so that what we did is that what
I would like to do is actually this
absolute vision as we get our technology
of running an automated industry have
will be able to record the spectrum and
then tap utilize the LED screen second
up to the set point that we know is that
tables are a problem so that you have
stables into the claws of yours
so this is when I have it with no period
as you saw in the photos as my life
we're in suppliant their own for the
horses go they're brought in my final
question this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu